good evening a welcome to Tucker Carlson
tonight when the founders of this
country designed the American Republic
something were grateful for obviously
but not everyone was impressed by it at
the time much of Europe scoffed at the
idea not just because they were
monarchist though many of them were even
free-thinking people of the time
contemporary liberals were worried that
it wouldn't work they didn't think it
would they thought that democracy was an
inherently weak system at some point
they believed unscrupulous politicians
would come to power change the rules in
their favor and establish a one-party
state what began as government by the
people inevitably would become tyranny
that's what they said at the time it has
not happened for more than two centuries
this country is relied on our
institutions are brilliantly designed
and remarkably durable institutions to
survive as an intact democracy and we
have through a Civil War two world wars
the Great Depression 9/11 and more all
of those events put great stress on our
system none of them broke it then came
2016 Donald Trump's election has
convinced many on the left that our
institutions no longer work
they must be torched and replaced by a
system that will prevent Trump and
anyone like Trump from ever being
elected again that's their goal and
they're starting with the judiciary at
least four leading Democratic
presidential candidates have suggested
packing the Supreme Court of the United
States enlarging its size adding more
Democratic appointees making it
explicitly political a tool of elected
officials rather than an independent
branch of government
here's Elizabeth Warren explaining that
changing the court is a form of revenge
for the crime of having a Republican
president first they steal a Supreme
Court seat then they turn around and
change the rules on filibuster on a
Supreme Court seat and so when it swings
back around to us what are we going to
do and my answer on that is all the
options are on the table
well apparently cory booker got the same
talking point the left is not in charge
of everything at the moment therefore
the Supreme Court is illegitimate Eric
Holder the former AG is talking about
expanding the number of people in the
United States Supreme Court beyond nine
to get more progressives on there where
you
I think we need to fix this in rune
court I think they stole the Supreme
Court seat can we keep it at night
should we keep it at no I think I would
like to start exploring a lot of options
and we should have a national
conversation term limits for Supreme
Court justices might be one thing to
give every president to be ability to
choose three every president gets three
justices keep in mind that for a century
and a half the court has been limited to
nine justices and by the way it's worked
just fine some of the Court's decisions
have been wise others have been
misguided some have been appalling but
Americans still generally trust that the
court is a real institution that's on
the level and that trust in the court
and other institutions keeps this
country stable when the public still
have trust in the court once it becomes
an arm of the Democratic Party well the
feeling is who cares what they think how
people feel is not a concern for the
Democratic Party right now they want
their power back now and forever and
that's why you're hearing calls to
abolish the Electoral College
state-by-state Democrats have already
been working to circumvent electors and
award the presidency to the winner of
the National popular vote Democratic
presidential candidates strongly approve
I think there's a lot to that 2016
national voting and that means get rid
of the electoral college
in fact the electoral college does not
favor one party or other and hasn't in
history in 2012 for example it favored
the Democrats if that election had been
tied in the popular vote Barack Obama
still would have won the Electoral
College keeps the country from becoming
a colony of California Chicago and New
York it demonstrates that America is a
union of equal states not a collection
of provinces that revolve around a few
powerful cities that troll college also
discourages the rise of factional
parties that dominate only a small
portion of the country we could go on
but the best argument for keeping like
torille college is pretty simple for 230
years it has worked better than any
other country systems in history but
because it didn't help the left win a
presidential election two years ago they
want it gone forever and along with it
any restrictions at all on who can vote
violent felons illegal aliens even
children that's the new Democratic
coalition whatever it takes I myself
have always been for lowering the voting
age to 16 I think it's really important
to capture kids when they're in high
school when they're interested in all of
this when they're learning about
government to be able to vote the
Supreme Court the Electoral College
voting restricted to citizens burned it
all down well stands in the way of the
left's request for power well let's see
how about the Senate left-wing
intellectuals already arguing the Senate
should be abolished
the border will left is already telling
us it's immoral to defend our border the
first and second amendments they hate
those they're speed bumps on the way to
total control the relics of a lesson
late in time our newly packed Supreme
Court could get rid of them and maybe
they will but keep in mind once your
institutions have disappeared it's
nearly impossible to rebuild them